Grand Theft Auto turns us all into bank
robbers and car thieves but have you
ever wanted to be the most notorious
crime boss and all of those Santos your
wish has been granted grand theft auto
online is getting a free expansion
called executives and other criminals
and it's bringing both gritty game modes
and luxury items to the table executives
and other criminals will not be coming
to PlayStation 3 or Xbox 360 but it will
be available for ps4 xbox one and pc on
December 15th it's bringing new
apartments new homes and new vehicles
like the sleek turreted limo and the
gorgeous super yacht the update will
also let you hire your own personal
bodyguards and what's a crime boss
without his protection also being added
to GTA online is a new mode called
extraction which sends those bodyguards
out to rescue a trapped executive before
he gets killed off existing modes like
king of the hill and moving target will
also play differently when your crime
ring takes part there's no shortage of
content for GTA 5 and this update is
piling even more criminal activity on
top of it we'll have more on executives
and other criminals when the expansion
hits next week until then keep your
sights aimed at gamespot.com